One of the first challenges with developing for mobile devices
is the display screen. The typically small screen, compared to a
desktop or laptop display, forces you to focus on what's really
critical for users. If the user on a phone sees your
investor relations link on your mobile web app's homepage, you're probably
doing it wrong. Unless your app is for an investment firm.
But of course, if you have more surface, you want to
use it. You don't want the small bit of text in
a big empty window design either. In fact, this
has what's led to the recent adoption of the mantra,
mobile first. It's not really about writing a mobile web
app or a page before the desktop one. It's really
about stripping your app or page down to its core
user functions. And then layering additional gravy back on top,
if you have appropriate room. This lesson and the following
ones are designed to give you tools to build designs
that can scale across multiple screen sizes and scenarios.
Now, the complexity of these lessons may lead you
to ask the question, hey, do I need to
be building one site that scales across desktop and mobile
or can I just have a separate mobile site?
No. Okay, that's a little strong, but there are
still problems with having separate mobile and desktop sites.
Which of these might be problems that you would encounter?